hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we are descending
deep down into the nation of curseland
once more in order to examine the hidden
inventory arc of jujutsu kaisen and
before i go any further i know for a
fact now that what we're about to go
through as well as everything from here
on out is going to be a spoiler for
anime only watches so there's your
warning continue to view and your own
risk but also seriously just like go and
read the manga i don't care how good the
anime is so far jiu-jitsu kaisen has
been one of my favorite manga
experiences of the last decade so just
do it you oh and just while we're here
this is
an impassioned belief from my used and
abused dms on social media
yes i am well aware that the chituchis
in prequel exists i have been aware
since the very first video i made but i
was told to read it very specifically
after hidden inventory so we will be
tackling that next so thank you to the
potentially
hundreds of you who have been trying to
maneuver my attention that way but i'm
well aware so you can now rest easy
although i suppose it's only fair that i
get bombarded with the same request over
and over and over again just as i will
proceed to bombard you with the
wonderful opportunity to subscribe to
the new world review the pressing of
this button being a domain for regular
jujutsukai's and content being uploaded
straight into your youtube feed and
since this is a domain i'm afraid that
this request
is a guaranteed hit so look it's your
fault for getting trapped now just push
the button and be merry but stepping
into hidden inventory was a bit of a
shock because we were immediately thrust
into a gojo-centric flashback so a shock
in all of the best possible ways and as
such not only do we get to learn a whole
lot more about this aloof figure but the
true stars of this story are ghetto who
we are finally getting into
as well as toji the mysterious father
men of one
fushiguru that and all of the world
building in regards to tengen who is a
fascinating figure all
in good time though because we are going
to begin in the only place i know how i
suspect that in an alternate reality we
could have had a version of jiu jitsu
that just featured gojo as the
straight-up protagonist
because this whole arc was about 15 or
so chapters without seeing yuji and
everything was
honestly it was pretty fine go driver
comfortably held up that mantle in yuji
stead and it was fun to watch him
develop into the gojo we know today
because
as flippant and arguably reckless as
gojo is in the monday his student years
were certainly
much much worse asking all sorts of
questions like a curtain's even
necessary does it even matter if regular
people see all this weird crap
as well as the whole idea of how painful
it is to look out for the week so he
certainly had a more simplistic view of
the world almost
optimistic really only truly developing
his revolutionary mentality towards the
end of the arc and while it wasn't much
there was some information given
regarding gojo's specific curse
techniques named limitless and six
eyes the combination of which are
apparently what makes gojo the
ridiculous curse boss he is
although six size in particular wasn't
expanded on and as a result intrigues me
greatly what we did get to do though was
a deep dive into limitless with all the
neutral blues reds and
purple business which was great because
we've seen gojo use these curse
techniques in the past but knowing how
they operate is always what i crave
and intriguingly this also delves
further into reversed cursed energy
which
put more simply can be called positive
energy which is apparently achieved
through a simple yet impractical
mathematic equation of negative times
negative equals positive which is an
idea that i think i sort of feared at
the beginning of jujutsukaisen i really
liked that this world dealt exclusively
with negative energy and theoretically
to become more powerful you would just
need to invoke more and more negativity
so higher risk for higher reward but at
the very least i do like that
right now anyway positive energy cannot
be achieved on its own it needs to be
summoned directly from the negative
and that concept in and of itself really
does sue gojo who seems to have chosen
the path
of embracing negative energy to change
the world around him as opposed to say
ghetto who comes to the conclusion that
we should just stop curses and negative
energy manifesting in the first place
how
you ask well mass genocide of course but
i do like that contrast
getting into ghetto i got quite a
legitimate shock when i saw him pop
up as a student so damn casually i mean
i know it's been implied or perhaps even
outright stated that he was a former
jiu-jitsu student i
honestly don't remember but seeing his
family smiley face was the exact
moment where i set up and went right
we'll in for a bit of a story here
because this does serve as the
villainous origin story of ghetto which
is perfectly contrasted against gojo
because as much as they may disagree
about the basics these two were very
much on the same page for quite some
time and the prime example i would cite
of that is that they both came to the
conclusion that they would let rico
choose whether or not she wanted to
merge with tengen so both displaying
this rebellious yet merciful and
compassionate nature and quite honestly
it's a bit of a jarring shift with
ghetto one that i'm not 100
sure i buy like it takes an awful lot to
transform someone from the paragon of
humanity determined to protect the weak
and all of
the good things to decide that killing a
large majority of humans on the planet
is the ultimate solution although i will
admit that it was quite disturbing to
see all of those religious cultures
supporting the death of an innocent
young girl
and deal with the death of a first-year
student and then stumble into the
village where all of the people wanted
to kill the curse-wielding little girls
so you know what sure it's the more
selfish self-preservation path where
ghetto would rather sacrifice the bulk
of humanity to protect sorcerers rather
than sacrificing sorceress to protect
the rest of the ungrateful swine on this
planet and i don't know it's hard to
grapple with because these specific
experiences ghetto is undergone do point
to this darker and perhaps even
unsalvageable aspect of humans
so i mean why bother protecting them if
they are the sole cause of everything
that's wrong in the first place and you
know the more i talk about it the more
i'm actually convincing myself of
ghetto's motivations so even writing
this out is a bit of a journey but still
let's say the ghetto is on the right
track you would still need to rid the
world of humans pretty much all at once
otherwise you're just perpetuating
negative energy because the surviving
family and friends and just other people
will fester into these gigantic negative
energy batteries like jinpe and that's
to say nothing of the people who are
both not sorcerers and also
don't output much negative energy like
bread girl and naomi's flashback i mean
why would we kill bread girl she is
amazing and she makes us delicious
delicious bread well you just cast me
yuko
or jinpei's mother fushigoro's sister
yuji's grandfather
all of these people who have a net
positive effect on the world anyway
we've probably spoken about this a bit
too much i do like that i
kind of understand where ghetto is
coming from now even if i do think his
ultimate
ideology is simplistic and just a little
poorly thought out and rather twistedly
he's very much become like the cultist
he's so despised but we do need to get
into our third star player a very
unexpected presence from toji fujiguru
when he was first brought up i thought
it would be for some sort of eventual
conflict between he and megami but i
think he was pretty perfectly dealt with
here he at once represents the great
potential of humanity going forward as
well as the profound danger he does the
former by being apparently the only
successful case of a human's cursed
energy being reduced to absolute zero
via a fun
heavenly restriction so that's quite
handy and perhaps a potential path
forward to rid the world of negative
energy
although perhaps even more wildly
impractical than even ghetto solution
but that's really what made toji so
fascinating because he presented us with
the antithesis of jujutsu sorcery
someone who was able to completely
counter those forces without a single
drop
of his own cursed energy and it really
does highlight the fact that jujutsu
sorcerers and curse wielders in general
may be far too
over reliant on that energy and not at
all prepared for the more basic of human
challenges which is something that we
have seen portrayed through both yuji
and maki with their raw strength and
speed but here we saw a tip
top source referral victim in gojo which
was pretty amazing
for the very first time introduced
kaisen we have confirmed that gojo
is indeed mortal no matter how
ridiculous his sorcery is he can still
be brought down by the right level of
planning which i imagine is going to be
an important factor in going forward
with the whole plot to seal gojo's
shenanigans
back to doji though i really liked his
whole gimmick of facing off against
curse users by wielding a spirit that
not only holds all of the funky weapons
but even om nom noms itself it was a
really cool idea and i'm kind of sad
that toji did meet his demise here if
only because i wanted to see more of
that spirit in use
all in all though toji did serve as a
very solid antagonist i would even go so
far as to say that he has the best
antagonist arc to date although to be
fair i suppose he doesn't have a lot of
competition because mahito and ghetto
still haven't played out their full
stories but toshi fushiguru is a
presence that i will always remember now
speaking of presences we have heard the
name tengen brought up before and it has
happened again he was mentioned during
the death painting arc but has become
phenomenally more intriguing during this
one wielding the cursed technique of
immortality
albeit immortality that does not prevent
aging so once every 500 years he has to
merge with an appropriate vessel which
is our primary conflict in this arc
although come to think of it
in the end that was more or less
pointless after that entire struggle
with rico tengen somehow stabilizes
anyway assumingly through finding
another vessel
maybe i don't know it's not explained
all i know is it's really sad because
ultimately rico's involvement and death
served zero purpose here whatsoever they
could have just left her alone to live
out a happy normal life
because in the end her death wouldn't
even satisfy the weird cultist dudes
because tengen just would have become
quote unquote
impure by another means so maybe the
sheer pointlessness of that struggle
also plays into ghetto's motivation to
stop this cycle of cursed energy i do
very much like the concept of tengan
though particularly because he is
currently unseen and to be honest i kind
of hope that we never see him there is
something so powerful about this image
consisting exclusively of words of this
immortal protector something that i
don't think visual art could ever
satisfy it's sort of like the idea of
the lovecraftian cosmic entities cthulhu
and such
they were written deliberately to be
beyond human comprehension and therefore
beyond artistic depiction and so every
time you do see a picture of like an
eldritch horror there they're kind of
underwhelming and while it's not quite
on the same level at this stage tengen
is such a wonderfully mysterious entity
that i don't think actually seeing him
could really ever live up to that oh and
i should also mention that gojo's
explanation of how tengen operates was
pretty perfectly spot-on as someone who
grew up watching digimon the idea that
we like metal greymon but don't want him
to become skullgraymon so yeah it's
better to just reset him back to coramon
made this situation ridiculously clear
if possible
i would prefer digimon analogies for all
arcs please now funnily enough this is a
bit of a strange arc that actually seems
to blend into the next one because the
final chapter of the arc spent about
half of its time wrapping up gojo's past
and the other half brazenly marching
forward into our next adventure which
commences with the discovery of the
filthy
mole which turns out to be a mecca mole
but the most intriguing part about this
is definitely the further discussion
about binding vows
because it is very intriguing that even
mahito was ultimately
unwilling to break said binding val due
to the completely unknown penalties
which is fair enough considering that
even sukuna seems to regard these vows
as some pretty serious business but that
makes me want to see someone break one
all the more
and as we conclude with the setup of a
newly reinvigorated makamaru about to
face off against majito
i do wonder if this will affect his
heavenly restriction in any way
because it's not really a restriction
anymore if the restriction part doesn't
exist so will his power be affected as
well or is mahinto just a glorified
cheat the system sort of existence with
his soul manipulating prowess i'm afraid
i don't have the answers to this
currently so i should
probably go and find out so that pretty
much does it for this bind review of
jujutsukai sen's hidden inventory arc
and what do you guys think please do
leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you're keen for some more juju to
sorcery then please do check out some of
my other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for very maybe
regular jujutsukai send morbidity
delivered straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review and i'll see you next time